there's been lots on trying to help
migrants of course and raising public
awareness raising money as well to try
and help people who are fleeing the
situations in Syria and in Libya and
elsewhere they're causing this migrant
crisis in the UK and when it comes to
people who help perhaps you wouldn't
necessarily think of lawyers as being
the type of people you would approach
but actually it could be surprised at
what they've actually achieved let's
talk to employment barriers to sean
jones you set up an online donation page
Sean good morning money and you ask
Stanley for people to donate an hourly
rate a billable hour a billable hour and
why I guess that's something that
everyone within the your profession you
know what your billable hour rate is
yeah it's like the fundamental particle
of our careers so you thought you did
what raised five grand or so I hoped to
raise five grand but we did that in
about an hour Wow and 48 hours later
we'd done a hundred thousand and went
out 108,000 say it's impressive obvious
it's a huge amount of money and it's
going to save the children which mean
obviously this incredible work are you
surprised at just how quickly your
colleagues have responded to this well
yes no and no because people like you
have done a fantastic job of resolving
statistics into people and as soon as
that happens I think hearts break
conscience as a pricked so I'm not
surprised people who wanted to do
something I'm just surprised that so
many people have done so much so quickly
it's not even just the money now we have
people who are doing what we call non
billable hours so the people who've come
together to do this are looking at how
they might use their skills practically
to assist charities and assist migrants
just just out of curiosity how much is
the average billable hour i couldnt tell
what the average is because it runs from
legal aid lawyers so yeah as you know
more or less nothing these days and yet
have been donating entire days fees
entire days hearing fees through to city
partners in magic circle firms who would
rather die than tell you how much they
earn
on average I have a station has been
over 100 pounds of person so it's been
very impressive is amazing here it's
interesting as you say about people
wanting to donate their skills and their
time as well I mean that no doubt can
actually have a very big impact for a
lot of these people coming through well
I hope so I mean we have it turns out we
have hearts and now it seems we have
some spare time too and I don't think
many lawyers imagine they had but we do
and people are prepared to provide
assistance and immigration law or
employment law all the things which
people come into the country are likely
to need how long is this are you going
to keep this going for I mean it
indefinitely or do you see an end point
where you're going to say right enough
is enough on this and look towards
another project perhaps I don't see a 10
point and whether it's sustainable
indefinitely I don't know but I think
the thing to do is to ride the mood and
whilst the generosity is there use it to
do whatever we can it's it is
interesting because lawyers get a often
get a bad rap like journalists and the
state agents I guess you can put the
three together and it's quite nice to
see lawyers who I mean by the very
nature of your work it involves other
people's misery often as as ours does
it's it is very nice to see that about
very positive response that's kind of
you i mean we have carefully cultivated
a reputation for hard heartedness and
ruthlessness so whether this is in our
commercial interest in the long term I
don't know but it's hard to look at the
pictures we've seen and not have your
heart rate cleaning to say obviously
said Save the Children and have you been
in touch with them do you know what this
is going to be used for and I've
certainly have been in touch with them
they've been incredible about it and we
understand it's going to be used for the
direct assistance for migrants and for
refugees and I mean they're operating in
so many different areas I don't think we
really mind specifically in which area
they use it as long as it's used for
their good work and what was
specifically inspired you was it that
photo of the boy in the beach or what do
you think do you think would've got the
same response say a few days ago a few
weeks ago and we've had I think about
eight hundred and ninety people respond
they'll all have their own reasons
that photo was important to me I'm the
father and I think it's just impossible
to look at it not see your own child
there and not want to do something and
we're just one of any number of efforts
going on right now and they're happening
because people have felt something needs
to be done by then it's not enough i
think just to wait to see what the
government does and organizations like
Save the Children provide a real and
immediate opportunity for people to help
so as soon as you point people in the
right direction of what they can do
they're more than willing to do it sure
good to talk to you and turn and I guess
it almost congratulations it all seems a
you know a little bit little bit strange
to say congratulations under the
circumstances but raising this amount of
money in a few days it's a phenomenal
achievement to you and your colleagues
isn't it well I haven't raised it I'm
just incredibly proud to be part of the
profession that's done as much as it has
so quickly sure thank you thank you